I have video for you today that's so
insane that I initially really wasn't
sure whether it was some kind of strange
satire although we've since learned that
it's not I have video of a relatively
young white guy in a New York City
restaurant it's a chain restaurant
called fresh kitchen seems like kind of
a sandwich and salad type place I'm not
familiar with it and in a story
originally reported by Latino rebels we
have video of a white guy who is just
furious because he heard Spanish being
spoken by employees in a restaurant
which if you've ever been to New York
City you know is not exactly a rare
occurrence right one of the things I
liked about living in New York City was
that a lot of my favorite neighborhood
spots in Brooklyn for example I could go
in and directly speak my native tongue
of Spanish to the staff the great
Italian place that I liked in Soho a
burger place and Brooklyn a great
Israeli restaurant on the Upper East
Side wherever I like the fact that you
go in and I could speak Spanish with the
staff needless to say if you live in New
York City I don't know how you would be
even remotely surprised about walking
into a restaurant and hearing staff
speaking Spanish so this guy shows up
and he starts screaming and ranting and
raving about how inappropriate it is to
be speaking Spanish in the restaurant
because this is America and the reaction
of the people in the restaurant was
basically to laugh and ask the guy to
leave which inflamed him even more and
got him to say these people are probably
undocumented and my next phone call is
to ice Immigration and Customs
Enforcement and Facebook user Edward
Suazo uploaded the video to his account
a couple days ago wrote that his wife
and her best friend had been chatting in
Spanish with a waiter when this guy
jumps in and the following chaos ensues
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so the guy's been identified online as a
lawyer in midtown Manhattan and I'm not
even gonna give you the guy's name he's
getting doxed and I just want to
participate in that stuff but he's been
identified his online listings have been
flooded with negative reviews the New
York State Bar Association was contacted
they said they're aware of the situation
but they don't really do attorney
discipline reportedly the law firm he
works for offers services and not only
Spanish but many other languages I don't
think there should be any official
disciplinary repercussions here right
the guy's free to say whatever he wants
obviously if he crosses the line into
some kind of threat of violence or
something that would be criminal there
would be legal repercussions but people
are free not to hire this guy if they're
put off by his comments which I would be
because he seems like an absolute
lunatic but here's where it starts to
get even more interesting in online
comments that starting appearing about
the sky people said hat we recognize
this guy this guy is on video at
far-right rallies in New York City
including one from I think about a year
ago where he showed up and verbally
attacked the rabbi as being a fake Jew
quite a special guy this guy in another
video again a guy who looks starting
startling ly similar to this guy is
taunting a group of Jews and flipping
them off with his middle finger here's
one video and it does look like the same
guy take a look
so back to the original video I actually
think just laughing him out of a
restaurant is is sort of the way to
handle this right he wants others to be
angry that Spanish is being spoken and
the totally nonplussed reaction of okay
yes Spanish is being spoken all right
what that's way better than people
starting to yell at him and become
aggressive because it's the indifference
to the fact that yes Spanish is being
spoken in New York City that's what I
think will most frustrate people like
this they want everybody to be mad like
they're mad and when nobody gets mad
this guy hates it I feel like the
restaurant manager should have been a
little bit more assertive but you never
really know how you're gonna react until
something like that happens yeah and you
can tell if this guy holds these racist
and xenophobic views but I'm sure he
doesn't go out and do this every day
something definitely set him off
beforehand I guess I mean if he did it
every day if he if every time you see
people speaking Spanish in a restaurant
you do this we'd have hundreds and
hundreds of videos of the guy unless
this is like the first time in years he
went to a restaurant and he was shocked
that at a restaurant in New York City
people were speaking Spanish people like
this guy want trouble they want
reactions they want conflict and I say
laughing it off and say we don't care
just go away is actually a good approach
and it is not a good week for this guy
if you look at what's happening to this
guy online and I don't endorse any of it
but it's really bad what's happening to
this guy it is not a good week for him
that I can assure you the video you just
watched was made possible by support
from you please go to patreon.com slash
david pakman show you can make a pledge
of as little as one dollar per month and
every dollar helps to support the work
that we're doing particularly in light
of the YouTube ad boycott which has been
really bad